good evening an update now to the story
about a five-year-old pulled from a fire
over the weekend in north las vegas the
little girl rescued by firefighters from
a town house on east nelson avenue right
near las vegas boulevard and cary
sally jaramillo spoke to family and
neighbors and brings us the story
good news malea was removed from the
ventilator and is now
speaking she is expected to recover and
family says they are forever grateful
for the north las vegas firefighters
my heart throw everything to me
lynn armstrong along with her
granddaughter calicia osorio are still
reliving what happened saturday morning
my grandma started hearing popping noise
and she thought about us and she ran up
the stairs and saw flames coming out the
laundry room
armstrong's first instinct was to get
her grandchildren
out of the home when i had woke up mike
was so strong
i knew malay was in there but she was on
the floor i thought she was
next to me a little bit kept trying to
tell my grandma you have to go get her
because that's all i wanted was her and
i wanted her to get out
fire chief joseph calhoun says the first
units arrived within five minutes
and malaya was located exactly 11
minutes after
in less than 21 minutes she was at umc
calhoun says this was a team effort from
the grandmother
to neighbors and first responders so i
ran out
and that's been a concerned neighbor you
know trying to go up there and see if i
can get the baby out myself
i'm so thankful that they got her out of
there because if
it wasn't for them she would have never
survived if she stayed in there longer
osorio says her sister means the world
to her and is excited that she is now
talking and getting better we're going
to have a lot of fun once
she gets out i appreciate all the people
that are
helping my family and donating money to
my grandma so that
she can get a new house fire chief
joseph calhoun also wants to remind the
community the importance of having smote
detectors
make sure they are clean and change
those batteries reporting sally
jaramillo 8 news now